there's a conspiracy theory that
powerful interests around the world are
manufacturing the end of days to force
the return of Jesus have you ever heard
this I have not
um that the the idea is they're trying
to implement the things described in the
Bible
so that they make the prophecy come true
intentionally that gives me chills yeah
that's that's one of the reasons like if
you talk to people that really hate
Christians and they want to call uh
people Nazis and stuff tend to be on the
left uh they say that uh Christians and
Republicans and stuff they they are
pro-israel because they want to kick the
Jews out the whole reason that you that
that Christians are pro-israel is
because they want to get rid of the Jews
and then they need to have a place where
they can send the Jews that's what the
left thinks of uh that's what they say
because everything to them boils down to
if you're not us you're a Nazi but so I
I the general idea is it's true all of
these things that we're seeing with
terms of the great reset you'll only
think you'll be happy the mark of the
beast uh like the way the internet is
making people as you described in that
you know when you read that Bible quote
Yeah is being done by by plan that's the
conspiracy theory all right and real
quick when you say mark of the beast I I
have another verse it says that if you
you will not be able to trade in the
marketplace unless you take the mark of
the beast are you familiar with this so
I'm like that's the mark of the beast
cbdc I'm like oh my God you're right not
what it would be because like you're
gonna pay with this digital currency
everyone everyone will have to have the
app to scan otherwise you can't buy buy
sell or trade and this is totally coming
like is it is it is anyone here at this
table suspect that that's not happening
isn't this exactly what they are saying
they yeah that is
the world economic form which loves you
and by the way there's no evidence They
Don't Love You There is no evidence
there's no evidence Bill Gates doesn't
love you there's no evidence Klaus
Schwab doesn't love you there is no
evidence you don't quote there's no
evidence there is no evidence like with
the elections and stuff just keep saying
it there's no evidence I love how Bill
Gates is constantly going like there's
just too many humans and we gotta do
something about it and and make less of
them yeah and then everyone's like
that's a conspiracy theory like dudes on
stage at Ted saying it giggling about it
you mentioned psychedelics might help
people overcome this pattern and create
a new pattern I found that does help me
personally create new patterns in my own
thought processes but like it's
something about when you sort of ego
death that made me think about Flow
State and this the state that scientists
have been studying fervently in recent
times where you you quiet your frontal
lobe which is where your ego your
personality your thoughts of me I it's
in your frontal lobe when you cool that
down and don't have activity up there
you go into this Flow State where and if
you're creative you understand Flow
State probably you've probably
experienced it at some points in your
life I'm sure of it
um and if when you're in that state you
kind of have control that control of
reality but you control it in a
different way you interact with reality
in a way where you're not like it's not
happening around you you are it right
I'm convinced that this is like when
people say like they debate about Choice
like what's his face what's that guy
that talks about Free Will
um that the he's a what's his name he's
made a big case for it uh Joe Hawkins no
no no no he's you see him around on the
internet all the time people look at the
cat uh comments talk about the guy who
talks about Free Will
um you'll know his name Sam Harris Bingo
Sam Harris and I'm like this is what
debunk said I don't believe that for a
second in fact I think that it's
extremely dangerous to make people think
they don't have a choice that is that
that's that's a lie that's the devil you
always have a choice but but it I and
the thing is is that I totally
understand his argument that if you're
born in a certain situation raise a
certain way there is you can react with
The Reptilian Brain so quickly it's like
you kind of didn't have a choice but
what you just described I believe is the
way around that which is that to take an
objective objective step back and with
that mitigating ego to so we now you
realize you do have a choice and you
don't have to act impulsively and you
don't have to you can actually choose to
think
um I think that that telling people they
don't have a choice is one of the most
dangerous things I think it's the big
scam yeah talk about Free Will and I
guess you would say what's What's Free
Will and determinism I think is the what
the two the two opposites well I think
that there is a form of determinism and
that we're in this magnetic field being
moved along magnetically with God and
they say are you with God because you're
moving with it but then you can you have
the free will to bend away from that and
kind of step away from God's plan and
create your own will and your own plan
and sometimes that can actually get got
it seems like get God to go along with
you and the rest of human entity to kind
of change change course a little bit and
you've kind of recalibrated determinism
for the entire species of all of reality
I got to push back on the magnetism
portion of it because if you were to say
like The Ether or something or this like
intrinsic field or something that might
be that might resonate more yeah
subatomic spin but but but what you're
saying is is physics buzzwords to
represent something that we can't
understand I'll stop using the word
magnetism it's too it's too big
magnetism's too big it's a much smaller
process but gravity no no but which I
think is a form of magnetism
my issue with this is like we of small
and limited mind have identified one
fundamental Force therefore we will
describe God as that and that's like
that that's just I think a bad idea that
doesn't make sense yeah it's more about
the way the Universe moves give it its
own word if you have to this like
unknowing no because spin is also a very
quantifiable and tangible sign thing
that we can we can study and replicate a
lot of the times if you're trying to say
that there's some kind of God field that
that unites and bonds people to God and
it's it's it's beyond you know our
understanding then I'm like ah all right
right some kind of like
some kind of field of energy the Higgs
field no no you're doing it again you're
doing it again you're never going to be
able to see it because it's always going
to be smaller than what you can
currently but it's not size the the
point that he's making is these are all
phenomenal you talk about phenomenon
that we can study and that we're
familiar with you talk about five
vibrations a lot vibrations are kinetic
energy we understand kinetic energy you
talk about electromagnetism
electromagnetism is is one of the four
fundamental uh forces of the universe we
understand that pretty well the only the
thing we don't really understand is
gravity so fair enough we don't know
where gravity comes from but the strong
effect yeah but it's time it's less it's
less understood
it's it's not it's it's gravity is not
pulling it bends space it's not a
pushing force it is pushing yeah you're
being pushed towards Earth
he's right he's right it's you know what
you're traveling through a straight line
through space through curved space space
itself is Bent by Massive objects so
that's why that's why like a a black
hole you can't get out because the
curvature of space is so much that you
can't travel fast enough to get out of
it you can the the speed of light is is
is faster or is slower than the speed
you need to go to get out of that
curvature Mass makes the field that we
exist in three dimensions up down left
right forward back Mass makes the field
we exist in curve it Bend that's what
gravity is but the strong force the
force that keeps subatomic particles
together the weak Force and and
electromagnetic uh the electromagnetic
force these are things that we
understand really well so if you're
talking about a new force or a force
that's unrelated to these that's fine
but when you use forces that we can
study and that that have been studied
for decades and decades and decades and
stuff you you tend to miss the you're
not making uh the connection that you
that you're trying to make you know what
I mean because you're using things that
we can relate to already that we have
have experience with and can and test
and stuff like that is I think what what
Tim's trying to say yeah but basically
it's like
imagine if you know an indigenous tribe
of people were like the sun is God and
we're all connected by the warmth of the
sun it's like we know that's not true we
know the sun sunlight is an
electromagnetic frequency that is coming
from this gigantic Fusion reactant
reaction and so if you're trying to say
that there is an uh an energy a
spiritual energy we we can't we don't
understand call it that but saying
magnetism is like me saying this clicker
remote control is what connects us to
God like no that's one small thing we've
identified maybe it's like the way see
this word again vibration we're just I
mean we don't have the tools to measure
this stuff but something that's cracking
like photons are appearing out of the
every time you say every time you say
vibration or Higgs or whatever all
you're doing is like picking up a rock
that we found and claiming that's God
all I can do is talk about bosons and
fermions the subatomic spin right now we
don't have the tools to see smaller than
that but but do you so you can talk
about them but do you know why you're
talking about them because you know
what's what do you understand the things
that you're talking about the way
there's spinning is determining whether
or not they become protons or neutrons
or electrons and then and it also
determines where they're going to appear
in reality and like when we look at
reality we think of it as moving across
but it's actually appearing in place
over appearing in place consistently in
a new position over and over and over
again you're not actually moving you're
appearing you're constantly appearing in
place in a new position so
um I think you can appear you can change
the way you appear
I don't and more than just positionally
like uh the but the way way is a vague
term I don't I don't you wanna you wanna
hear a mind F to go along with talking
about the Sun and God real quick and
we're talking about all this the the the
subatomic particles so something like 94
or could be 96 of all elements in
existence emit from the Sun
give that a Google
something like uh over 90 like 94 is
what I recall of all elements in
existence emit from the Sun yeah Google
it yeah but but you've got to clarify
what that means you mean that it is
Stardust we are made right right
Stardust Fusion reactions within Stars
create elements yes yeah right not the
sun the sun is a microscopic component
of of reality the sun is one of many
generators that are producing up to 94
of all matter apparently all matter that
exists came from is constantly being
emitted from Suns and exploded
there's six percent of it that's not
coming from Stars they that might not
even be the case it maybe it is they
don't realize it but I know that these
elements also come from um deep sea uh
heat vents you know what I'm talking
about like superheated vents they're
finding that the building blocks of life
are being admitted to from that which is
unbelievable because we're talking about
superheated we're talking about molten
rock it's being a minute out of that so
like when you think about the fact that
we are quite literally made of star dust
by definition and the fact that we're
now sitting here talking about it is one
of the biggest mind apps for me because
I'm like what is this kind of creation
to me that's evidence of intelligent
design not everyone listening is going
to like that but I'm like that's kind of
weird the fact that I can
conscientiously choose to even discuss
it and talk about it and present it is
like the biggest that run really gets
here's the sad reality around uh
creationism intelligent design whether
it's secular simulation or religious
you know when you play a video game
the video game might have stars in the
sky but there ain't nothing up there
it's just a picture and if we are in a
simulation if we are in a creative
Universe for our experience then space
is just pictures okay nothing up there
it's all down here and we're all alone
just us here for ourselves or at least
that's all we can observe like I like to
use the analogy of like an ant like you
so ants are very sophisticated and you
drive like hundreds or thousands of ant
hills every day and they have absolutely
no concept whatsoever that there is
somebody inside or even of a vehicle
itself but somebody's in it going from
to their job it's like beyond their even
realm of comprehension so maybe it's
like that's not a human comprehension
right for sure our brains are so limited
relatively so potential this is this is
great this is one of the answers to
fermi's Paradox uh for those that aren't
familiar I assume most of you are it's
if the universe is so big and aliens uh
exist why have have we not discovered
intelligent alien life it could be that
we are ants next to a super highway that
we can't comprehend and we look up at
the stars going wow I wonder what that
does meanwhile super Advanced species
which are well beyond human
comprehension are zipping around
multiple different dimensions and times
and just like They Don't Care About Us
in much the same way that we don't care
about ants yeah I realized if when we
actually tweeted this out when we Master
the communication we can't hear the
aliens will come there's a body language
when you can speak communicate with your
thoughts once once the human race
Masters that ability I think telepathy
yeah just think words at people instead
of saying them you you communicate with
your body language that way do that
right now to me and then see if I can
get it
this is how you do it dad nothing man
I'm sorry I'm trying to I don't know but
what happens when you think of somebody
and they call you guys have had some
pretty spectacular oh dude we've all had
those moments where you grab your phone
and then right when you turn it right
when you press like wake up it's you
answer the phone call at the exact
moment and it's the person you wanted to
call not wild right what is that is it
just coincidence no I don't think hold
on back in the day when we had landlines
this happened to me maybe three or four
times in my life I walk up to my phone
to call my friend I pick the phone up
and there's no dial tone and I'm like
what's going on then I hear some noise
like hello and then my friend goes hello
and then I'm like uh
who it rick he's like oh oh yeah I just
got oh wow I just called you and I'm
like whoa wait what jaw dropping I
picked up the phone to call you right
when he dialed the number and on his end
it never rang he dialed the number and I
was instantly there on the phone and
he's like huh and for me I picked my
phone up and he's already on the phone
I'm like what just happened and The
Crazy Ones is when it's somebody you
hadn't talked to in a long time maybe
it's months maybe it's a couple years
and all of a sudden like you get like an
email or you get like a DM or a phone
call or a text like what's that about
what are the odds sometimes I wonder
like I've had these moments from like
this goes beyond the realm of like
coincidence and sometimes it's on the
day where something had happened that
reminded me of them or I heard that song
because like songs are an interesting
way of taking you back in time like I
could hear a song on the radio and be
like oh I was in the seventh grade I
remember this because I was doing this
with these buddies you know what I'm
talking about and so I'm like sometimes
when things happen like that it makes me
like a believer I'm like this there's I
don't know how we're all connected if
whether it's a one Consciousness or what
but sometimes I think there's way more
going on than Beyond the Veil of the
human eyes have you read about
near-death experience yeah I I've read
uh I read this book long time ago like
20 years ago now or like 18 years ago
and it was talk like a lot people said a
lot of the same things like they died
they could see a bright light they felt
warmed they felt like they were being
lifted up and uh one book I read said a
common theme was
they felt like they were being pulled
towards this very large ball of light
but they could see other balls coming
towards it as well
and I'm wondering just I thought are we
all small for we we are all pieces of
the universe obviously yeah but is it
possible that the energy and
Consciousness within us is a fraction of
the greater entity of Consciousness
gnosticism when we die we go back and
rejoin concentric circles that's all
gnosticism
yeah the gnostics believe that God is
the demiurge god is actually Satan and
there is a God above God which is the
Gnostic God they believe that that God
has broken itself apart and it's in
every living being and every every
person and the goal of people is to
realize that we are God and when we do
that then we will uh forget the phrase
uh but we will become one with the uh
the ultimate or one with the the only
one if you don't do that you like I
don't know the whole detail I don't know
it's a religion that I don't know a
whole about but I do know that
gnosticism believes that that the god
that is worshiped like the the uh
judeo-christian God and Islamic God is a
is actually the devil and that the real
God has broken himself apart and is
inhabiting all of us and when we realize
that we are God then we will have like
that will actually be the beginning of
time like mine hasn't started yet my
religion is that when you die you wake
up in an arcade with your buddies
playing Street Fighter too you take you
take off the headset and you were like
oh that was crazy is awesome yeah and
it's like you know you you you you die
and then next thing you know you're
sitting in an arcade you take the helmet
off and then your buddies are like dude
you were a rock star in a band called
All That Remains I feel like yeah it was
great when you talk about God this
Gnostic God and how it's within all of
us I'm thinking about how there's a
theories about how the universe is like
white holes and black holes and that the
black holes are sucking matter in and
then it's transporting it or
transmitting it and it's bursting out of
these white holes which are stars and
and then I wonder if we have white holes
within our protons or within what's
causing the subatomic spin to actually
spin what's gestating that that momentum
is there a white hole is it some sort of
explosive force that's being withdrawn
through black holes and is that God
coming out of us like bro you ever
program a video game uh yeah well I used
game maker so way back in the day so for
for a lot of people I'm not you know RPG
Maker I'm not so I'll say two things one
in uh video games what they do now is
only what's in your field of view is
rendering and when you move it rapidly
renders the objects around saves memory
and is easier to process but uh when I
used to do uh game maker stuff uh
multimedia Fusion flash if you are
making a game let's say you're like uh
uh what's a what's a Galaga yeah is that
your little spaceship and then the Space
Invaders plus yeah that was a big
upgrade in the in the future iterations
of these games where your your overhead
view of the little spaceship and it's
you know shooting the guns and then
getting the power ups and the bad guys
are coming down what is really happening
is that if you were to take the video
game screen and zoom out and see beyond
what the screen could show you there are
other objects outside of your field of
view just above your little spaceship is
a block with no graphic design object we
can call it object a
object a is the creation point where
obstacles are are descending from and it
moves around basically creating uh not
necessarily creating but the way the way
it worked in the games that I at least
is the games I made them if you were
playing a game where your platformer
running forward and and I would want to
Generate random enemies and obstacles
there would be an object that moved up
and down and then I would the code would
say something the effect of
every uh you you'd create a variable so
that it could so that it would generate
between you know like between one and
ten seconds
uh you know at random create object 17
at y minus one object a and what that
means is that object that moves around
is the point at which the game fires the
the obstacle the enemy so let's say
you're playing Mario and a bird comes
across the screen there's something
that's in front of you you can't see do
you think that's happening in reality
well so I bring that up because that's a
white hole
while the white holes you described it
where matter is coming out of could just
be a spawn point for matter that the
simulation or God uses I only question
if it's random because we use that word
random but I don't I don't see any
evidence that any of this is random
hmm I mean I I can only assume that well
like you said Jimmy we're talking about
this primordial soup that's not right
this isn't like oops we accidentally
fell down and now we're humans talking
about it and the fact that we have
feelings the fact that like you know
it's like talking about like what we do
matters the fact that when you do
something wrong there's this weird
feeling about it and you can talk about
what's wrong and you know that's
debatable but like the fact that there's
feeling as well as something called love
we all like you can't prove that it
exists but like we all know it right
does it not exist yeah what's that about
and people let me just say people say
that's like survival like oh well you
needed to like a companion whatever I'm
like I don't know I think that you know
you could argue that love is almost like
the you know it could destroy a lot of
people in some ways I don't know we're
gonna say I didn't mean to cut you off
like no there's a lot of life in this
planet that doesn't have love
yeah yeah trees as far as we can tell
don't experience the same existence we
do in fact when I look at a tree I see
essentially the same thing as fire
a comical reaction now you can make the
argument that plants of course are not
and sold in the same way as humans are
and humans are unsold and that's what
creates everything you've described I
bet they are they have circulatory
systems I I got to tell you though like
you know Sheamus says that there's
different kinds of Souls and that that
idea generally makes sense to me because
there's no way that
you know when I look at a dog you can
tell a dog's emotions oh yeah you know
that dog has not the same but similar
feelings and emotions and expectations
and even even you know cats cats are
very different they're more independent
but like I can this is the thing like
Roberto Jr died he was he was uh he's a
rooster we raised one of the first that
we hatched we got these original
chickens Roberto knocked him up we
didn't realize her but it was a boy we
take a few of the eggs that are
fertilized we incubate them they were a
weak batch only one remains kind of sad
but Roberto Jr has had kids and I did
not shed a tear for Roberto Jr I am not
that upset that he died it's sad it's
like ah Roberto Jr he was our dude you
know he's the mascot for our coffee
but roosters don't have that emotional
connection or actual like mammalian Bond
or whatever
I just he's a rooster he was funny he
looked at me he he you know that's
that's it right Mr bocus Marquette and
the other dogs that we have here
express love and affection in a way that
is relatable and understandable to
humans that humans feel I bet if you
trip balls on acid with Roberto you
would see his eyes and you look in his
eye for like an hour and you're just
looking in his eyes you'd feel it I
don't I don't agree they're they're
birds birds are like they bang their
kids like Roberto's banging his
daughters and stuff like that I'm like I
don't I don't feel any connection to
these things they're food yeah you know
I like them I don't want them to be hurt
it's sad when they die I don't cry when
they do it's that when bogus gets sick I
get worried and if it hurts my feelings
it's that brain creature like the brain
brain stem that's floating in salt water
that we all have even birds like The
Reptilian right right yes yeah it's the
brain and the stem it's all one creature
it looks like an octopus kind of like it
it fell down into the ocean living in
salt water now it's like surround me
with a sticky wet a meat sack to contain
the salt water and it'll come out of the
ocean and carry carry the salt water
around with me but where these like
floating octopoid thing these weird
things that are like tugging on muscle
with electrical impulses and we all
share that all the animals have a brain
I think every is it safe to say every
animal has a brain no no oh no flat
worms so shrimp once you start shrimp
once you start getting into brain
creatures that that's like
I don't know if that's if we're if we're
different like whales got big brains
yeah brain creatures that's a cool one
octopus yeah their whole body is pretty
much a brain it's kind of all eight
tentacles see the problem this
interesting thing about alien life
uh if if alien life was I think if we
were ever to discover alien life that
was traveling the Stars they would be
very similar to us
very similar in fact they'd probably
breathe the same the same atmosphere the
reason being uh uh the the octopi is a
very intelligent creature super smart
ain't never going to smelt or create
computers why it's underwater but what
if it creates what if we created a body
that it can live inside of in salt water
no what what do you ask yeah could it
could it manipulate a body robot from
inside a robot like our brains do with
our body so we create a a robot with a
water tank on top and the octopus is
inside manipulating controls and
communicating in a way that it can
translate to English and then we can
actually interact but what you're doing
when you say can we put it into a body
is you're saying can we take this
creature that has no reference of what a
human experience is like right so we as
humans can look at an octopus and
understand that thing thinks differently
to us because the experiences that we
have have a significant impact on
ourselves so if you took an octopus that
has eight tentacles no spine all of
these different things that to what we
humans are the way that it experiences
reality has to be totally alien to us so
if you put it into a human like a robot
with a human type of body there's no
reason to think that it would understand
or even know what to do and so like like
the idea of it being like whoa we'll
just take the this brain and put it into
the the robot that we built like it was
from Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles that
like it wouldn't there's no reason to
think that it would understand or see
things the way that we do you know what
I mean the the way that we experience in
the world is very particular to human
beings well the monkeys have you seen
the monkeys working on computers like
touch monkeys are totally different
they're not smart monkeys are totally
different than octopus monkeys are
bipedal they have hands they have faces
octopus are totally different creatures
I suppose then instead of saying putting
in a body just build an interface for it
so that it can somehow let us know that
assumes that it could interface right so
hold on Ian what he's saying is
you might you look at Food you think oh
that that piece of cake looks delicious
the octopus might not even think in
these terms so we can even understand
well have you seen the octopus in tanks
they'll see another fish in another tank
they want it they they search the tank
they find a crack they slide up they
move through they'll even climb out of
water and climb across the land and
everything that it does is like an
octopus the point that I'm making is
there is no human there's no reference
for you to take an octopus put it into a
situation that a human understands and
think that the octopus could understand
it out of a human being would never look
like you could never be in a tank and
then be like oh there's a crack in there
I should try and shove myself through
because you're a human it doesn't come
to you like that experience doesn't work
but sound for instance with AI brute
forcing
a computer program could probably work I
think we're getting close to the point
where an AI could figure out
Communications between other animals
yeah I see where you're going and that's
that's crazy right that's reasonable
that's fine so you think about how we
have this AI rapidly learning and how
it's creating all these images imagine
if we just had you know when we do
capture here's the thing the amount of
data we give to AI is insane we don't
have that with say a fish or an octopus
we go on dating apps we go on Twitter we
go on all these apps and we give our
data up that are fed into this machine
this computer which then rips through
all the data and then figures out how to
replicate and understand what a human is
imagine if we made chat GPT but it was
based on all the sounds a dolphin made
and we just had a bunch of
supercomputers running through all the
different sounds dolphins make and then
like making the sound and seeing how
Dolphins react over a long period of
time and then eventually deciphering
dolphin communication yeah crazy right
and then you can actually make a dolphin
translator where you can and dolphins
are intelligent yeah but the thing is
you could you could say like uh we're
gonna throw in some fish if you want to
move to the left and then he goes yeah
and then the dolphins all go left and
then you throw the fish in thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time